hello and welcome to another video here
blitz chess
against hmm um
now you can read it and probably do a
better job than i do
all right got a fiance here against his
setup not clear yet that's the king's
indian could have still played a
grunfeld or something else like with c5
or c6 let's see it's going for this
knight c6 a6 line
i don't know this for white really i
i know that this is going to
be one of the lines that i will check
for my upcoming
um english opening repertoire
the lifetime c4 knight f3 repertoire on
chestable but i have not yet
again studied this in any reasonable
detail
so b5
i don't know you go d5 now
i don't think this should be
particularly great
but i don't know why
knight d5
you can make an argument for that move
knight d5 takes takes
yeah that's probably not good actually
anyway taking on d5 i mean
knight d5 cd5 knight before queen b3
should be pretty awful
and we take c4 i think it can take f6
and
play rook c4 i think this is actually
the correct
theoretical way to play but i'm kind of
making this up
so i'm not sure about it
okay so what what about this
i can take and then play b3 or i can
take and play c5
c5 maybe
e5 bishop h6
yeah let's do that it shouldn't be too
awful
yeah but maybe just queen detour a
couple of
pretty natural moves available for white
in general this should be simple to play
[Music]
i'm somewhat slow on not slow small on
that webcam
hmm i have some
back and forth settings there
some of that software has forgotten some
of the settings while i was on vacation
because the external webcam was not
attached and somehow
things are odd
okay so black is taking a long time okay
this is
not something i had on the radar at all
i thought bishop h6 now should be good
yeah d5 and c6 this isn't that
bit awkward
maybe not so d5 where is he going with
the knight to e7
yeah it's not so bad for him
maybe bishop h6 wasn't actually that
good
yeah pushing the d5 c6 looks wrong
really if you take a closer look
what now now
d5 and e4
maybe maybe his pieces look a bit
a bit awkward let's try
i mean knight d2 e4 wow okay
i didn't even consider that one
maybe not so bad i'm just i'm just
saying i have didn't think about it at
all
interesting
not easy to okay
cover e1
i would like to trade the dark squared
bishop
make d4 a bit weaker
no it's not easy to do
at all
interesting so he claims that
i shouldn't play b3 because of rook c3
it's definitely
a point
maybe queen f4 and bishop
to f6
this and then there's d3 maybe
is it actually an idea to simply let him
play rook c2
it could be a thing i'm just down on
time
bishop f5 i have overlooked actually
oh
wow my queen has no squares
that was sick wow that was terrible to
lose that position
i'm fairly certain that this is just
good for white i mean
it shouldn't be bad at least so
engine says equal so maybe black has
enough activity for this bad structure
i should definitely not lose quickly
yeah i think i lost a bit of time there
with a couple of moves yeah that's
probably the problem
so this i wanted to cover e2 again so in
case of a capture
yeah this is just a totally wrong idea
hmm so something like h5 is roughly
equal yeah
bishop f5 is even more um
of a problem but of course i made things
worse
i didn't see bishop e5
interesting i'd like to i'd like to
check this a little bit
so this is i think fairly normal bishop
d7
and the engine wants to take and play d5
now
yeah maybe
i played c5 instead
maybe c5 is not right i'm i'm not yet a
specialist of this position
and this line there's certainly some
ideas also taking is
definitely making some sense i would
expect
pawn takes though not rook takes i mean
rook takes looks ridiculous
pawn takes and then like d5 knight d4
yeah this is certainly better for i
think
i mean i don't know i don't know this
opening variation but
if this is good somehow for black then
there's something
it doesn't really make sense to me why
would you
weaken the c file and so on it's a bit
strange this line
um at least for my positional taste but
it is played frequently so it cannot be
bad
but taking on b5 here seems to be better
c5 does not really
this is not really convinced so
computer wants to do this though knight
d4
then take and play b4 okay
yeah interesting this is this is
um not great then yeah knight d4 is a
good move
i mean i was thinking knight e7
but then i think after e4 i'm better
because the knight has no squares
yeah and these pieces look look pretty
ridiculous so
97 is not good knight d4 is really a
better move
with hindsight i wonder if i mean okay
after the capture it's equal right so
that was not a mistake
but i'm also far away from being better
so the real point is probably around
here when i should not
play c5 but rather take on b5 that is a
much more
convincing way to play and also more
strategically consistent with what i did
i still wonder why the engine gives rook
takes i would think that after b3 i
should be just
eternally better because of this strange
pawn structure
and okay the engine gives me some kind
of advantage but
isn't this better ape takes or
is the sorry the backward c pawn
yeah okay where do you go with it no
idea
knight a5 or yeah a7 can't be bad
i can't cannot be good i'm sorry and uh
this is kind of okay
now i don't know these lines um so well
yet
some that sometimes can be a problem if
you
try out some new opening variation like
i'm trying this out currently and
i mean i know some lines um if if they
play let's say c5 or so i'm
pretty much i'm knowledgeable but in
some lines i'm not yet so far
um yeah my progress is not
yet so far in that new um
repertoire so i don't know that yet all
right thanks for watching